thank you so much for inviting me to
come speak my name is Diego and carita
and
chair of coop our qua powers located in
Hatfield Massachusetts but it represents
various different regions within
Massachusetts and the surrounding
communities myself live in Holyoke
Massachusetts so-called power is an
inclusive multi-class multi race
cooperative it's it's a consumer-based
cooperative it was developed in the
early 2000s when the municipal musically
run utility companies were going to be
deregulated and residents throughout
Massachusetts were starting to organize
and think about an alternative way to be
able to retain local control over energy
and qua power really basis model on the
energy cooperatives that are located in
the Midwest area of the country the the
difference is that it really has a
social justice lens to it and it's it's
kind of created this ongoing dialogue in
tension within the cooperative to hit
all these different points you know a
triple bottom line some people call it
one of the reasons why the co-operative
model was so prevalent in the Midwest is
that as the coastlines the East Coast
and West Coast became electrified it was
the Midwest that was kind of left out
and so a lot of folks became they
developed and traditional engine energy
cooperatives in order to electrify the
middle area of the country quapaw was
really focused on renewable energy and
not so focused on traditional forms of
energy so this is kind of a timeline of
quad power so it started beginning its
community planning and business
development in 2002 and eventually
incorporated in 2004 and one of the
biggest projects that i was looking at
was launching this biodiesel company and
i'll talk a little bit more about that
later but the story a little bit of the
story of the biodiesel company is that
it was supposed to be launched in 2005
and you can see there
QWOP our turn down a venture capital
offer to build the company because there
was a real focus on who owns it matters
and being able to ensure that you know
when the cooperative members invest
their money into a business like that
they're investing their money for the
long term with long-term outcomes and
not necessarily just trying to make a
profit so here's part two of the
timeline 2010 qua power purchase to
structure for community renewable energy
products at this point in 2010 that's
really when energy efficiency became
targeted as the the main product that we
could use to develop to generate revenue
for the co-operative there was one
member in particular who had a lot of
experience in energy efficiency that
brought this service to us and we really
focused it on performing energy
efficiency for our cooperative members
and though they were located throughout
the region Hampshire County Franklin
County I'll show you them up in a second
so you can see and then eventually there
is a launch of them the solar
photovoltaic panels on top of the
brattleboro food co-op and the launch of
enter here which I'll tell you a little
bit more later and then another energy
efficiency crew in Boston and hopefully
in the next year 2013 2014 we're going
to finally be able to launch northeast
biodiesel and scale up our community
solar so this is uh when we talk about
where that where the member is located
we organized the co-operative into what
we call local organizing councils and
the idea is that while the co-operative
is one entity they're allowed it allows
us to have more local conversations on a
regular basis so we organized into
different regions there's southern
Vermont Franklin County Hampshire County
hampden county metro Boston eason
this kind of wooster Providence area the
Blackstone Valley as it's called and
what's really interesting about this
model is that all these different
communities are they look very different
the local organizing councils
demographically look very different they
have very different challenges when we
look at the mission of being a
multi-class multi race cooperative we're
always you know have debating is this is
that a definition for the entire
cooperative is that a definition that
has to apply within every single loc
it's it's always a constant conversation
and right now we have an energy
efficiency crew in hampshire county and
franklin county and then boston we're
probably going to launch another one
here in worcester and there's a certain
radius for when we are crews do work
they don't usually go outside of western
mass and or boston and so Worcester
usually doesn't get doesn't have any
service right now from our energy
efficiency cruise until they launch a
crew and southern Vermont had the
photovoltaic panels installed on the top
of the food co-op and hamilton county is
where we launched energia and so for
co-op our room we do energy efficiency
we focused mostly on residential homes
we go into the homes of our cooperative
members and other leads that we get and
the crews go in and do insulation and
energy audits it's really based off of
this program that we have in
Massachusetts called math save and mass
save is supported by the government and
it's a way for folks to be able to get
subsidized energy audits and be able to
do energy efficiency work on their homes
and that's a really good way for us to
get in the door with a lot of homeowners
sometimes when you go a kilometer was to
go to a bank and ask for funding or to
get alone to be able to do this kind of
work whether it's solar hot water
installation or it's some installation a
lot times will get turned down because
it's a pretty non-traditional that it's
green it's like they're if they're not
as likely to fund it to give a loan
but the really key area that folks who
were in this industry I found is that
when you're when you're buying a house
when you're already taking out a logical
in to buy a house that's a good time to
be able to incorporate you know go to a
bank and say I want to make some
improvements general improvements get a
new hot water heater make some
improvements to the house that's a
really good time to add in those extra
cost to be able to invest in your home
at that point and massive is kind of
like an opportunity for folks to be able
to not have to wait when they're in that
moment to be able to start doing some of
that work that being said that's created
challenges with you know Rhode Island or
Vermont when they've been asking going
back to the whole cooperative in saying
well how are we going to be able to get
energy efficiency services if we don't
have mass age so that's an ongoing
conversation so this is kind of a
breakdown of the the flow of coop our
and it kind of you know we can set off
as being a quap our member co-op our
member puts in equity and can give loans
to the different products and businesses
and receive products and services for
their membership and that goes into the
co-op our council which then develops
new products and services green jobs
education and community control and then
the whole cooperative provides
investments loans and business
development to create green businesses
and good green jobs which produce energy
products and services interest in
dividends and so it's a really unique
model in the sense that we're focusing
on alternative energy instead of
traditional forms of energy so these are
kind of a some of the great things we've
done so far we've launched ten community
on green businesses and 150 good green
jobs northeast biodiesel we are starting
to generate a little bit of revenue and
her he has launched we have five solar
installation businesses we've helped to
launch westfield energy efficiency trade
center to green electricians and then
the coop our programs are their solar
vendor network
potential energy efficiency services
neighbor to neighbor is a program that
we do where we try to cut down the cost
of being able to install solar hot water
so we get a discount on the actual
machinery for the device and then within
our own membership we organize and kind
of like a barn-raising used to be we get
together everybody and we just install
it on someone's house and someone who
knows how to do is there supervising and
watching but it's you know we're coming
together and helping each other and then
you know if you get one on your house
and you're going to go and help someone
else put it on their house so it cuts
down the cost of labor in that and then
community solar is one thing that we're
we're looking at researching more we've
already have our first pilot when we put
the photovoltaic panels on the
brattleboro food co-op so energia my
other life outside of co-op our I work
for in Westeros arises which is in
Holyoke and Holyoke is a community that
is very distinct from southern Vermont
or Franklin County it's I think it's 51%
Latino of that Latino majority or Puerto
Rican it's a community that's been hard
hit by the the flight of the
manufacturing industry and so there's a
lot of unemployed people in Holyoke and
the average age of residents in in
Holyoke are 25 and there's one
neighborhood in Holyoke where the
residents or the average age is 14 so
there's a lot of young people who are
unemployed and sewer system is a total
failure and so there's a lot of meetings
there's a lot of needs in Holyoke and
Melissa psoriasis works on agriculture
and has gardens and has a farm and also
has a youth program and as young people
have been going to the youth program and
western US races there's been a need to
be able to you know take that next step
you know college isn't the path for
everybody so a lot of young people need
that that time between 18 and 24 to be
able to get a job just regularly and
just figure out what is going to happen
with their life and so
kia was this collaboration that came
together between west psoriasis qua
power and another CD seen were left
bonanza to be able to launch a an energy
efficiency commercial business that
would then create jobs support an
environmental impact in terms of
reducing energy costs and then generate
revenue for the nonprofit organizations
be able to do environmental justice work
it was launched in 2010 it's not easy at
all to be able to do this kind of
collaboration takes a lot of trust and
conversations and we got lucky and it
was successful last year we had 1.2
million dollars in revenue were
projecting to have 1.3 million dollars
in revenue this coming year and after
three years we're expecting a check up
ten thousand dollars from energia for
nuestras raices from our investment
Weston said Isis owns fifty-one percent
of the company qua power owns fourteen
percent with Bonanza owns five percent
and there's also an aspect that there's
a workers trust so the workers are
actually able to buy in and be worker
owners of the company so yeah that's
it's a really great story and the
company hired 19 of the young people
that vs-rs is trained so some of the
results of community ownership
democratic control to owner member and
community participation means that you
have a community-driven agenda and it
created leadership is developed and then
you have an increased leadership
development attention to the member and
worker and community needs
decision-making focused on meeting needs
versus just making profits increase to
worship of natural resources this is
really difficult to get consensus on
everyone has different agendas so we're
always battling of that with the agenda
so I don't want to like gloss it over
and just say readers want to Jen there's
multiple agendas so profits decisions
made by community members profits are
distributed to members and/or used to
build other community resources stronger
local economy more community
met more stable local economy increased
increase in community owned assets
increased standard of living I will say
that the jobs that Energia and the
energy efficiency crews that they
provide or pay a lot better than the
jobs that a lot of young people get in
the mall like serving food or working at
TJ maxx by northeast biodiesel so this
was a project that was supposed to be
the first business launched by coop our
but um when a venture capitalist came in
and they have the discussion we're
talking to the to the board and to the
members and saying you know we can build
this and I can put in all the money and
then i'm gonna i need my investment back
within like two years and i'm gonna
retain control and be able to make all
the decisions for a certain time period
and that really didn't sit well with the
membership and they really decided to
vote not to go with it forward with the
venture capitals even though it would
have launched the business at that time
period and that really speaks to the
fact that the members are really believe
in the mission of co-op power even if
you know folks are putting in money I
mean a lot of the thing but you know the
would it cost to become a member for the
majority of people was around over nine
hundred dollars and then if you're just
part of the bio the fuel buying group
it's around two hundred fifty dollars
but the majority of the people are
putting in around nine hundred dollars
not paid all at once some over a longer
period of time but to be able to say you
know I'm going to trust my money with
this vision of a different kind of
economy so this is what our biodiesel
plant looks like currently it's got some
of the tanks and then the processors and
I'm going to show you how the processors
work so this is up in Deerfield so what
is biodiesel we base our biodiesel and
recycled vegetable oil not virgin oil
the the economic model for virgin oil
doesn't work as well as recycled
vegetable oil so when you have just
regular vegetable
you get that from restaurants and
cafeterias converted diesel vehicles
with special handling can run them on
the just oil alone and special oil
recycle special recycled oil furnaces
and boilers with special handling can
can run on the soil but has to go to a
process to remove the glycerin and then
we sell the glycerin as a by-product and
then you have pure biodiesel and then
any diesel vehicle in warm weather can
run on that where a furnace and then you
go through a process of blending it with
petrol diesel or number two heating oil
and then it becomes as biodiesel blends
and and at that point you can especially
for where we live use it and any deals
to a vehicle or any furnace or boiler
and so the way that we're structuring
northeast biodiesel is that we do have a
section of ownership for investors you
know folks who want to invest but aren't
necessarily members of the cooperative
and we do have a member owner a worker
owner percentage as well kind of like
how energia was structured and then qua
power are the majority owners and after
time the investors will be paid back and
the worker owners will take up their the
seventeen percent that they that they
owned one of the the biggest issues
right now is we've kind of figured out
that in terms of financing the
finalizing this company it's that our
members put in the first four hundred
thousand dollars right we they've
already put in four hundred thousand
dollars of loans and then we've also got
commitments for a number of people and
banks to say well we want to be the last
money in well it's like everyone wants
to be the last money in and we also have
our members saying they're the first
menu but there's this middle amount of
funds that we're looking to raise that's
around like six hundred thousand dollars
and the we have a really good business
plan we approached one bank that would
be interested if this wasn't a start-up
so it's kind of like working against us
it's a startup it's a green industry
it's an industry you know biodiesel got
a lot of flack for a number of years for
the food crisis overseas I mean this is
not based on virgin
it's based on recycled oil but still
biodiesel has kind of a bad reputation
but um in terms of where we are
regionally we'd be able to supply enough
that we're looking to do quite a
substantial volume of biodiesel and be
able to make it available in the area
and I think that's it so thank you